i
[Música]
la ola invernal en eeuu no da tregua al
menos 2.7 millones de residentes en
texas desafiaron su tercer día sin
electricidad luego de la dura tormenta
que deja 21 personas fallecidas
el gobernador exigió que los
legisladores estatales investiguen ayer
con la entidad responsable del 90 por
ciento del flujo eléctrico en ese
territorio
facebook prevé compartir publicar o leer
noticias de medios de comunicación en
australia dentro de su plataforma se
trata de una medida de respuesta a un
proyecto de ley del gobierno que
obligaría a las compañías digitales a
pagar por divulgar información de medios
en la red social
las protestas continúan en mi amar con
cientos de miles de personas en las
calles este jueves para pedir la
renuncia de los autoproclamados líderes
militares tras el pasado golpe el
primero de febrero 11 funcionarios de la
cancillería fueron detenidos mientras
existen órdenes de arresto contra seis
famosos por incitar a las movilizaciones
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 cerro blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en eeuu texas superó el tercer día de
tormenta de invierno sin electricidad la
tempestad dejó 2.7 millones de casas sin
energía y al menos 21 personas han
muerto en cuatro de los estados
afectados el gobernador de ese estado
greg abbott ha exigido que los
legisladores estatales investiguen a la
compañía eléctrica ercot y aprueben
reformas lo propio dijo el alcalde de
austin steve adler que el culpó de los
cortes de energía a la falta de
preparación las autoridades locales
están en el centro de las críticas por
el desabastecimiento de agua y de
electricidad se espera que el frío
extremo dure todo el fin de semana el
sur en cuotas pedí una orden efectiva a
partir de hoy hasta el 21 de febrero
para requerir que los productores que
envían gas natural fuera de texas lo
vendan a los generadores de energía de
texas a word gear riders australia
despertó con un facebook diferente la
red social ya no permite a sus usuarios
compartir noticias
informativos en la plataforma que vengan
de un medio de comunicación una decisión
que ha causado indignación entre la
población y que se da porque el gobierno
australiano impulsó un proyecto de ley
para que facebook pague a los medios de
comunicación por su información pero la
red prefirió bloquear todo este tipo de
contenido ahora el acceso a la
información en australia podría estar en
jaque
la sentencia llegó este jueves en
australia millones de usuarios de
facebook ya no pueden compartir
artículos de información o vídeos en la
plataforma
las primeras consecuencias de este
bloqueo son alteraciones en los
servicios de socorro de salud y de
metereología en todo el país
nos encontramos frente a una decisión
desagradable tratar de conformarnos con
una ley que ignora las realidades de la
relación entre la red y los editores o
dejar de autorizar los contenidos
informativos sobre nuestros servicios en
australia con el corazón pesado elegimos
la segunda opción la red social tomó
estas medidas como represalia a un
proyecto de ley destinado a obligar a
las plataformas a remunerar a los medios
de comunicación por sus contenidos para
facebook esta legislación se acabaría su
modelo económico y el mismo
funcionamiento de internet
por su lado el gobierno australiano
busca ayudar a los medios tradicionales
en problemas financieros
igualmente en el punto de mira de las
autoridades de esta google quien terminó
encontrando un acuerdo con canberra el
gigante americano se comprometió a pagar
a los editores de prensa unas
compensaciones que suponen millones de
dólares al año
this is a histórico
hay un momento histórico la primera vez
en el mundo que los gigantes digitales
entran a negociar con los medios
australianos esto nos permite sostener
durante años el periodismo de interés
público en nuestro país y dirige el
mundo hacia una reforma crucial y ding
world en el crítico macro way que no
micrófono una reforma para repartir de
manera más equitativa los ingresos de
publicidad y que francia también busca
con un acuerdo que cerró con google este
enero un acuerdo que abre camino para
remunerar a los diarios franceses
vamos ahora está francia donde se debate
hoy en la asamblea nacional el proyecto
de ley que pretende fortalecer la
protección de menores de edad víctimas
de violencia sexual esta iniciativa
había sido presentada el 5 de enero y
remitido a varias comisiones para su
discusión vamos a estar parís
precisamente con nuestra periodista
natalia ruiz
natalia muy buen día cuáles son los
puntos más importantes de este proyecto
de ley
y muy buenos días para todos ustedes
bueno pues el gobierno de manuel marco
ha pedido que se adapte aún más el
derecho francés para proteger a los
menores tres puntos muy importantes de
que contiene este proyecto de ley el
primero la prohibición de relaciones
sexuales entre un adulto y un menor de
15 años de hecho en caso de acceso
carnal pues será considerado
automáticamente como una violación algo
que cambiaría lo que es hoy pues la
víctima tiene que entrar a demostrar que
se trata de una violación que ella no
había consentido a este tipo de actos
otro de los puntos es que se refuerce el
castigo o las penas digamos cuando se
trate de incesto de hecho el incesto por
ahora es considerado en el derecho
francés como un agravante cuando se
trata de algún tipo de violación o de
agresión sexual pero según este texto de
ley pues estas relaciones incestuosas
quedarían prohibidas entre un adulto y
un menor esta vez de 18 años una crimen
y con esto pues el incesto pasaría a ser
un crimen incluso pues se tendría una
pena de hasta 30 años de cárcel y el
tercer punto es uno que seguramente pues
va a ser muy
debatido porque es un gran punto de
discordia tiene que ver con la
prescripción de los crímenes sexuales
hasta ahora la ley en francia pues se
dicta que estos crímenes prescriben 30
años después de que la víctima cumpla 18
años algo que las asociaciones no
quieren esperamos que haya tal vez algo
un cambio allí cuando se trate por
ejemplo de un mismo autor que haya
cometido estos delitos indiferentes con
diferentes víctimas
natalia gracias por la información buen
día nosotros continuamos con más en el
estudio sigue la búsqueda en nigeria de
más de 42 personas entre ellas 27
estudiantes que fueron secuestrados de
un colegio la madrugada de este
miércoles en el estado de níger ubicado
al oeste de nigeria las fuerzas de
seguridad iniciaron la búsqueda de las
autoridades de los autores del ataque
este hecho se produce apenas dos meses
después del secuestro de 350 estudiantes
en una escuela en la ciudad de khan cara
al noroeste del país que se atribuye el
grupo yihadista
boko haram quiero saludar en este
momento a marta summers docente en la
universidad francisco de vitoria de
madrid y coordinadora
de terrorismo yihadista en magreb y
también sahel para el observatorio
internacional de estudios sobre
terrorismo gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france24 le pregunto por qué
estos hechos como estos los reportados
ayer del secuestro masivo de estos
estudiantes son constantes en nigeria
pues sí buenos días encantada de estar
aquí con vosotros efectivamente en esto
no es esto no es algo fuera de lo
habitual en esta zona de nigeria de
hecho en la última década las redes
criminales en principio no tendrían que
ver con con grupos yihadistas o
terroristas han matado a más de 8000
personas y han provocado más de 200.000
desplazamientos forzosos
el secuestro es una de las de sus
principales fuentes de financiación
suelen pedir rescate por por todos estos
civiles secuestrados pero él
efectivamente como comentaba es el
secuestro de qantara supuso un
importante cambio cualitativo en esto ya
que por primera vez relacionado con boko
haram fuera del estado de borno está en
la otra punta del país y es donde los
terroristas suelen suelen operar así es
marta ahora me pregunto por qué si estos
secuestros no son algo nuevo que ocurre
en nigeria como les estábamos comentando
porque el gobierno toma medidas
contundentes para que esto deje de
suceder o en menor cantidad menor medida
si hasta ahora la principal problemática
en el gobierno se ha centrado ha sido en
el terrorismo yihadista que está de
liderado bueno por las dos facciones de
boko haram la del seca y la fina estado
islámico y entonces sus esfuerzos se han
estado concentrando en esa lucha en el
extremo noreste del país
y los bandidos han sido operando con
relativa impunidad en la zona centro y
en la zona oeste lo que pasa que durante
el último año esta problemática ha ido
ha ido empeorando los ataques se han
recrudecido y ha habido una mayor
presión social que ya finalmente con la
implicación oficial de boko haram en el
secuestro de can cara o sí que ha
provocado un mayor despliegue de las
fuerzas de seguridad en esta zona centro
y occidental pero ya te digo que esto
pues llevan son redes criminales que
llevan por lo menos diez años operando
allí son realmente fuertes entonces no
es nada fácil de combatir ahora quiero
totalmente marta lamentable situación un
gusto haber conversado con ustedes
gracias por su tiempo
nosotros vamos hasta mianmar donde las
protestas continúan con cientos de miles
de personas tomando las calles para
pedir la renuncia de los autoproclamados
líderes militares a pesar del gas
lacrimógeno y las balas de goma lanzadas
por las fuerzas de seguridad entretanto
11 funcionarios del ministerio de
exteriores fueron detenidos ante la
junta militar emitió órdenes de arresto
contra seis famosos por 15
para las movilizaciones contra este
golpe de estado la junta militar ha
realizado al menos cuatrocientos noventa
y cinco detenciones veamos el informe
[Música]
los manifestantes en mianmar no muestran
signos de rendición y han vuelto a salir
a las calles el jueves por la mañana
incluso ante el aumento de la represión
por parte de la junta militar la noche
anterior las fuerzas de seguridad
dispararon balas de goma sobre los
manifestantes en la ciudad de mandalay
los trabajadores del ferrocarril pararon
trenes como parte del movimiento de
desobediencia civil y cientos de miles
de manifestantes a lo largo del país
tomaron las calles en medio de las
huelgas en curso las grandes protestas
de hoy muestran que queremos que la
comunidad internacional sepa que no nos
vamos a rendir
les estamos instando a actuar
las protestas también se están llevando
a cabo en la red
el grupo hackers de mianmar atacó varias
páginas web gubernamentales al tiempo
que los militares siguen con el corte de
internet en la capital hubo plegarias
por la recuperación de mí a tweetdeck
ine una joven de 20 años herida de bala
en la cabeza en una manifestación el 9
de febrero los médicos no esperan que
sobreviva la onu está presionando para
imponer sanciones económicas y decretar
un embargo de armas ante el temor de que
la violencia se recrudezca
webb el pueblo de mianmar es consciente
de lo que es capaz del ejército y estos
generales porque ya lo he visto
por eso la presencia del ejército de
tropas de eeuu ha instado al ejército
birmano a poner en libertad a todos los
civiles y líderes políticos detenidos de
manera injusta aún san suu kyi la líder
electa democráticamente fue arrestada al
inicio del golpe y se espera que
comparezca ante la justicia el primero
de
y en japón fue nombrada la medallista
olímpica seis hojas y mató como
presidenta del comité organizador de los
juegos olímpicos de tokio 2020 así mató
tendrá la tarea de llevar a cabo las
justas a cinco meses de su apertura en
medio de la pandemia y tras la renuncia
el pasado 12 de febrero de su anterior
responsable yoshiro morí por la
repercusión de unos comentarios sexistas
así mató participó en siete olimpiadas 4
invierno como patinadora de velocidad
sobre hielo y en tres de verano como
ciclista de ruta
matías martínez de 25 años policía en
licencia psicológica asesinó a su pareja
úrsula bahíllo en rojas a 300 kilómetros
al norte de buenos aires en argentina el
más reciente caso de violencia de género
en un país en el que muere una mujer
asesinada cada 29 horas el presidente
alberto fernández se reunió con los
padres de bahíllo y se comprometió a
terminar con este tipo de violencia
mientras el movimiento ni una menos
sigue gritando pasta en las calles de
todo el país informados muñoz
18 veces había denunciado a su
maltratador y 18 años tenía úrsula
bahíllo en el momento de su asesinato
fue el 8 de febrero tras ser atacada con
un cuchillo por su expareja su madre
pide justicia y en memoria de mi hija
que estuve arriba del cajón rezando la
constantemente se lo prometí a ella que
voy a ser justicia el miércoles miles de
mujeres salieron a las calles de
argentina al grito de ni una menos
una proclama que ya es un movimiento en
un país en el que una mujer es asesinada
cada 29 horas y que desde el 1 de enero
cuenta con 50 muertes violentas de
mujeres trans y travestis según el
'observatorio mujeres de la patria
latinoamericana datos que se transforman
en una demanda vasta que todos en azúcar
las peticiones han llegado a la casa
rosada el presidente alberto fernández
anunció que el gobierno avanza para
crear un consejo federal para el
abordaje de los feminicidios través
decidió si trans feminicidios también
pidió a los gobernadores unidad contra
la violencia de género y recibió a los
padres de úrsula bahíllo alberto
fernández me escuchó como mamá
me voy totalmente
contenta a pesar de la tristeza que
tiene mi alma de lo que el presidente
se ha comprometido con nosotros un
compromiso institucional presionado
desde las calles
lamentable que siga ocurriendo este tipo
de casos en nuestro continente y en todo
el mundo así que el informativo de
france 24 continua con nosotros muy buen
día
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo